everyone was desperate for a visit
without any problems the police acting
quickly subtly moving the king away
Charles waving as a man in his twenties
was arrested for allegedly trying to
throw an egg
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
nothing like the egg throwing scene that
we saw in York
in fact in testing times it was largely
a warm embrace from luton's diverse
crowd it's a historical yeah we're proud
of Luton and we have a really tough that
is called soon because nobody usually
comes to Luton and we only hear negative
things about lutons it's nice to have
something positive about Luton this was
the first time he's been out since those
trailers were released for Harry and
Megan's docu-series and the racism
claims against the palace last week
Sean and Raja closed their office for
the morning so all the staff could come
to see him and to see what he does for
us for our country
yeah and then with everything there's
always a process there's not instant so
even if like people might have concerns
or things like that it's not something
that you can just change overnight like
Roger said it's work in progress but
that's something that we all contribute
to
and you're prepared to give the king
time yeah to make a make a real
difference everyone any job everyone
needs a bit of time but negative
headlines are a challenge for a man who
wants to be seen as approachable less
formal right from the start of his Reign
really celebrating diversity and
embracing an inclusive Britain has been
a huge part of the work that he's been
carrying out but again this is going to
be one of those weeks where we find out
how much what he's doing on the ground
can really combat those allegations
coming from Harry and Megan we may not
have to wait until the series is out on
Thursday in New York tonight they are
due to be given the Ripple of Hope award
for their work Standing Up Against
Racism we wait to hear if they're going
to speak
the king's advisors will always say this
is a man who is Heir actively supported
all communities all faiths
an important moment to reflect from
Monarch who must brace himself for what
more is going to come Rhiannon Mills Sky
News in Luton